in this segment we provide a high-level
introduction into the conceptual
framework of classical statistics in
order to get there it is better to start
from what we already know and then make
a comparison we already know how to make
inferences by just using the Bayes rule
in this setting we have an unknown
quantity theta which we model as a
random variable and so in particular
it's going to have a probability
distribution and then we make some
observations and those observations are
modeled as random variables and
typically we are given the conditional
distribution of the observations given
the unknown variable so these two
distributions are the starting points
and then we do some calculations and we
use the Bayes rule and we find the
posterior distribution of theta given
the observations and this tells us all
that there is to know about the unknown
quantity theta given the observations
that we have made what is important in
this framework is that theta is treated
as a random variable and so it has a
distribution of its own and that our
starting point these are our prior
beliefs about theta before we obtain any
observations however one can think of
situations where theta maybe cannot be
modeled as a random variable suppose
that theta is some universal physical
constant for example the mass of the
electron does it make sense to think of
that quantity as random and how do we
come up with a probability distribution
for that quantity one can argue that in
certain situations one should not think
of unknown quantities as being random
but rather they are just unknown
constants they are absolute constants it
just happens that we do not know their
value or there may be other situations
in which even though we may think that
there is something random that determine
theta we are reluctant to postulate any
prior distribution we do not want to
impose any biases and that leads us to
the classical statistical framework in
which unknown quantities are treated as
constants not as random variables
pictorially the setting is as follows
there's an unknown quantity that we wish
to estimate and we make some
observations X those observations are
random and they are drawn according to a
probability distribution and that
probability distribution depends or
rather is affected by that unknown
quantity so for example for one value of
theta the distribution of the axis might
be this one and for another value of
theta the distribution of the axis could
be a different one and we're trying to
guess what theta is which in some ways
is the question do my data come from
this distribution or do they come from
that distribution in order to make a
choice of theta what we do is we take
the data and we process them and after
we process them we come up with our
estimate or rather estimator what is the
estimator we take the data and we
calculate a function of the data that's
what it means to process the data and
that function is our theta hat now this
function our data processing mechanism
is what we can call an estimator but
quite often or usually we also use the
same terminology to call theta hat
itself an estimator now notice that
theta hat is a function of the random
variable X so theta hat is actually a
random variable and that's why we
denoted with an uppercase theta on the
other hand after you obtain some
concrete data little eggs which are the
realized values of the
variable capital X then we can apply
your estimator to that particular input
and we compute a specific value call it
theta hat lowercase and that quantity we
call an estimate so this is a useful
distinction always with random variables
we want to distinguish between the
random variable itself indicated by
uppercase letters and values of the
random variable which are indicated with
lowercase letters similarly the
estimator is a random variable it's
essentially a description of how we
generate estimates who arrests the
realized value once we have some
specific observations at hand that's
what we call an estimate now let me
continue with a few comments the picture
or the setting that I have here suggests
that X is just one variable and theta is
one variable but we can have the same
framework even if X and theta are
multi-dimensional for example X might
consist of several random variables and
theta may be a parameter that consists
of multiple components now you may
notice that this notation that we're
using here is a little different from
our traditional notation which was of
this form in what ways is it different
the main difference is that here theta
is not a random variable theta is just a
parameter so what we're dealing with
here is just an ordinary not a
conditional distribution it's an
ordinary distribution that happens to
involve inside its description some
parameters theta just to emphasize the
point that these are not conditional
probabilities because theta is not a
random variable we use a semicolon
instead of using a bar and since theta
is not
and variable we do not include it in the
subscript down here when we talk about
the classical setting the best way to
think of this situation mathematically
is that we are essentially dealing with
multiple candidate models as in this
picture this could be one possible model
of X this could be another possible
model of X we have one such model for
each possible value of theta and if for
example I were to get data points that
sit down here then a reasonable way to
make an inference could be to say these
data are extremely unlikely to have been
generated according to this model these
data are quite likely to have been
generated by this model so I'm going to
pick this particular model so even
though we're not treating theta as a
random variable and we do not have the
Bayes rule in our hands we can still see
at least from this trivial example that
there should be a reasonable way of
making inferences and let me close with
some comments on the different types of
problems that we may encounter in
classical statistics one class of
problems are a so called hypothesis
testing problems in which were asked to
choose between two candidate models so
the unknown parameter as in this example
can take one of two values so think of a
machine that produces coins and coins
are either fair or they have a very
specific bias you want to flip the coin
maybe multiple times and then decide
whether you're dealing with a coin of
this type or of that type there's
another type of hypothesis testing
problems which is a little more
complicated for example this one we have
one hypothesis which says that my coin
is fair versus and alternative
hypothesis in which my coin is unfair
but notice that this hypothesis actually
includes many possible scenarios there
are many possible values of theta under
which this hypothesis would be true we
will not deal with problems of this kind
in this segment or in this lecture
sequence instead we will focus
exclusively on estimation problems in
estimation problems the unknown
parameter theta is either continuous or
can take one of many many values what we
want to do is to design an estimator a
way of processing the data that comes up
with estimates that are good what does
it mean that an estimate is good an
estimate would be good if the resulting
value of the estimation error that is
the difference between the estimated
value and the true value if that
difference is small you want to keep
that difference small in some sense
well one may need a criterion of what it
means to be small and whether we want
this in expectation or with high
probability and so on this statement to
keep the estimation errors small can be
interpreted in various ways and because
of that reason there is no single
approach to the problem of designing a
good estimator and this is something
that happens more generally in classical
statistics typically problems do not
admit a single best approach they do not
admit unique answers reasonable people
can come up with different methodologies
for approaching the same problem and
there is a little bit of an element of
an art involved here in general one
wants to come up with reasonable methods
that will have good properties and we
will see some examples of what this may
mean but again I am emphasizing that
there is no single best method so
whereas the Bayes rule is a completely
unambiguous way for making inferences
here in the context of classical
statistics there will be some freedom as
to what approaches one might take